احذر فقط تكون ضحيه لتناول وجبه مشويات
معده من لحم حمير قلق يداهم العراقيين بعد
اغلاق مطعم شعبي في محافظه النجف قيل ان
صاحبه يستخدم لحوم الحمير
الامن الاقتصادي والامن الوطني اغلق مطعم
الحج في حي الامير بسبب مخالفات صحيه
كثيره اظهرتها مقاطع فيديو نشرت على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي اضافه الى صور اظهرت
اشلاء حمير قيل انها تابعه لهذا المطعم
لم تكتفي مفرج الامن الاقتصادي بذلك فقد
اغلقت محللا للحلويات فضلا عن عشره مطاعم
اخرى قيل انها مخالفه الشروط الصحيه ولكن
الجدل العراقي لم يغب عن هذا الحادث
متابعونا اشادوا بهذه الخطوه لكنهم اكدوا
ان هنالك مطاعم عراقيه تشهد مطابخها
مخالفات كثيره لكنها محميه بالمال والسلطه
واخرون اكدوا ان الحج لم يستخدم لحوم حمير
لكنه مخالف الشروط الصحيه ولا نقاش في ذلك
اما البعض فتعامل مع الحارس بسخريه كما هو
الحال مع باقي الازمات في العراق
[موسيقى]
ظاهره بيع الحمير ليست بالجديده في السوق
العراقيه ففي سبتمبر من عام 2009 نشرت
احدى الصحف العراقيه تحقيقا صحفيا ذكرت
فيه ان هنالك مزاد لبيع الحمير يعقد في
منطقه الرحمانيه والشيخ علي ببغداد ويحضره
العديد من متعهديه المطاعم والقصابين وان
بيع هذه اللحوم ادى لارتفاع اسعار لحوم
الغنم والمواشي في السوق العراقيه